Existen pocos fármacos con péptidos inhibidores hoy día,
pero hay muchos que ingresarán al mercado en la próxima década.
Veamos de qué están hechas estas medicinas,
qué tienen de diferente y a qué se debe esta ola próxima
de nuevos y emocionantes medicamentos.
Los péptidos inhibidores son proteínas diminutas.
Tienen enlaces químicos extra que inhiben la forma de la molécula,
y esto los vuelve increíblemente estables y potentes.
Ocurren de forma natural: nuestro organismo produce algunos
para ayudarnos a combatir infecciones bacterianas, fúngicas y virales.
Los animales como las serpientes y los escorpiones
usan péptidos inhibidores en su veneno.
Los fármacos hechos de proteínas se denominan fármacos biológicos.
Aquí se incluyen los péptidos inhibidores
y también los medicamentos como la insulina
o medicamentos de anticuerpo como el Humira o el Enbrel.
En general, los fármacos biológicos son muy buenos
porque evitan los posibles efectos secundarios de los fármacos comunes.
Primero, la proteína.
Es un material totalmente natural y no tóxico del organismo.
Las células producen decenas de miles de proteínas diferentes,
y prácticamente toda nuestra comida tiene proteínas.
En segundo lugar, los fármacos a veces interactúan con moléculas del organismo
con las que convendría que no.
En comparación con los fármacos de moléculas pequeñas,
es decir, fármacos regulares como la aspirina,
los fármacos biológicos son muy grandes.
Las moléculas interactúan cuando adoptan formas que encajan a la perfección,
como una llave en una cerradura.
Una llave más grande tiene más ranuras,
por lo que tiene más chances de encajar en una única cerradura.
Pero muchos fármacos biológicos tienen un defecto: son frágiles.
Comúnmente se los administra vía inyección,
pues el ácido estomacal destruiría el fármaco si fuésemos a digerirlo.
Los péptidos inhibidores son lo contrario.
Son muy durables, como los fármacos regulares.
Así que pueden administrarse vía pastillas, inhaladores o pomadas.
Esto hace que los péptidos inhibidores
sean atractivos para los creadores de fármacos.
Combinan algunas de las mejores características
de los fármacos biológicos y de las moléculas pequeñas.
Desafortunadamente, es muy difícil
rediseñar los péptidos inhibidores que encontramos en la naturaleza
para que sean fármacos nuevos.
Aquí es donde entro yo.
Crear un fármaco nuevo es como crear una llave
para que encaje en una determinada cerradura.
Necesitamos la forma exacta.
Pero si alteramos demasiado la forma de un péptido inhibidor,
los enlaces químicos extra no pueden formarse
y toda la molécula se desintegra.
Así que debíamos descubrir cómo controlar la forma.
Fui parte de un equipo científico
que incluyó decenas de instituciones pertenecientes a tres continentes
que se unieron para solucionar este problema.
Adoptamos un enfoque radicalmente distinto al de otros equipos.
En lugar de cambiar los péptidos inhibidores de la naturaleza,
descubrimos cómo construir nuevos péptidos desde cero.
Para conseguir esto,
desarrollamos software de diseño de péptidos de código abierto y gratis
que todos pueden usar.
Para poner a prueba nuestro método,
generamos una serie de péptidos inhibidores
que tienen gran variedad de formas nunca encontradas en la naturaleza.
Luego, comenzamos a producir estos péptidos en el laboratorio.
Lo siguiente fue determinar su estructura molecular mediante experimentos.
Al comparar nuestros modelos de diseño con las estructuras moleculares reales,
vimos que nuestro software puede posicionar átomos individuales
con una precisión que está en los límites de lo que es posible medir.
Hace tres años, esto era imposible.
Pero hoy contamos con la capacidad de diseñar péptidos
con formas que resulten adecuadas para el desarrollo de fármacos.
¿Cuál es el futuro de esta tecnología?
Pues bien, recientemente,
mis colegas y yo diseñamos péptidos inhibidores
capaces de neutralizar el virus de la influenza,
de combatir el botulismo
y detener el crecimiento de células cancerosas.
Algunos de estos nuevos fármacos
se han probado en animales de laboratorio en ensayos preclínicos
y, de momento, todos son seguros y muy efectivos.
El diseño de péptidos inhibidores es una tecnología de vanguardia,
y el proceso de desarrollo de fármacos es lento y precavido.
Aún faltan de 3 a 5 años para los ensayos en personas.
Pero en ese tiempo, más fármacos con péptidos inhibidores
ingresarán a la cadena de desarrollo de fármacos.
Y en última instancia, creo que los fármacos con péptidos diseñados
van a permitirnos librarnos de las limitaciones de las enfermedades.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)